hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
in front of an enthusiastic audience a
35 year old trevor milton stands on
stage proudly proclaiming his latest
achievement
the year was 2016 and the charismatic
energetic trevor seems like he's just
about to change the world behind him was
his tool to do just that
it was a truck running on revolutionary
hydrogen technology
it could save both money and the
environment
this truck called the nikola one was
going to disrupt the one trillion dollar
trucking industry and would go on to
make trevor a multi-billionaire
bosch general motors and other big names
all wanted to work with trevor and his
revolutionary company that would later
be worth 34 billion
the only problem was that none of this
was real the vehicle behind him was
simply a shell that couldn't even drive
itself and none of the technology that
he talked about even existed but this
would only be the beginning of the lies
so how was everyone fooled and how could
a man look so confident about his
achievements while knowing that none of
what he was saying was real you were
watching cold fusion tv
today it seems like the world of
startups is having its fair share of
charismatic swindlers
from theranos to wirecard the game plan
is simple pretend that you have a
revolutionary technology or business
plan gain billions in investment and
finally fake it until you can cash out
with billions
in the case of nikola motors you might
just end up with a 34 billion company
to understand how we got here we have to
go back
our story starts in utah with trevor
milton
trevor was born in 1982 and had a rough
upbringing his mother died of cancer
when he was just 14 years of age and he
would witness her coughing up blood in
her latter days
trevor and his four siblings had to
learn how to survive with a bedridden
mother and a father who worked four
hours away
it could be said that these experiences
made trevor driven he wanted to make
something of himself
milton and his father were close many
years later they would even go into
business together but that comes later
in the story
after high school milton took a mormon
missionary trip to the favelas in brazil
the experience got him thinking about
wider problems particularly
environmental ones
he would return back to utah in 2003 and
would attend the utah valley state
college to study sales and marketing but
he would drop out after just one
semester he had his eyes on bigger
things he wanted to start his own
company and so he did his first company
dealt with security alarm sales and
trevor would sell off the company for
three hundred thousand dollars
but in this deal there were already
signs of trouble according to the buyer
of milton's company he overpromised the
potential of the business resulting in a
loss for the buyer
milton also allegedly cheated his
business partner out of fifty thousand
dollars during the sale
in 2009 he would move into the online
ads business with a website that sold
used cars
trevor would then move on from selling
used cars to building vehicle power
plants and if you think this was a bit
of a leap it was
he had no formal training in the
industry
undeterred though this effort would come
in the form of d-hybrid the plan was to
transform existing diesel engines to run
on compressed natural gas
now this idea was solid natural gas has
less emissions lower maintenance costs
and is overall safer
the execution of his plan however was a
disaster
[Music]
as mentioned trevor had no formal
engineering experience but after some
good marketing he managed to convince
the company swift transportation to
invest two million dollars
in the deal
10 trucks would be converted as a trial
run then later 800 trucks
but as it turned out trevor wasn't
pulling his weight in the deal a 2012
lawsuit revealed that only five trucks
had been delivered
in addition the engines had major
problems and didn't do at all what they
claimed
and to top it off part of that two
million was squandered on personal
living
milton was simultaneously bleeding
through investor money and needed more
in 2012 he tried to find another
investor in utah to buy out the company
but they smelt a rat and backed out of
the agreement
to run away from all of his legal
problems trevor started a new company
with his father it was called d hybrid
systems
d hybrid systems and d hybrid were
completely different companies and the
similarities in their names was
intentional
trevor and his father now had complete
ownership and would work on the same
technology but now without the legal
problems this move left the whole d
hybrid partners with nothing
as outlandish as this was the plan
worked and a new company worthington
industries paid 16 million dollars for
their company the only problem was that
the company was in shambles
in private conversations trevor admitted
that parts of the engine systems were
falling off the trucks something he
stated was potentially fatal
at the end of the day all that mattered
for trevor is that the deal was paid out
for him and his father
i freaking
helped design and develop and fix all
these repairs that
worthington didn't know about these back
of cab units were actually falling off
of the trash truck falling off the trash
like breaking off they were shearing the
damn freaking frames and then coming off
like nearly freaking causing deaths and
stuff
in 2014 trevor founded what would become
nikola motors
meanwhile worthington was losing
millions the faulty engines that
dehybride had given them was causing
nothing but problems milton was making
money while the companies that he sold
off were money pits
milton would continue to convince people
that he had valuable technology
on may 9th 2016 nikola motors announced
the nikola 1 a semi-truck that would
revolutionize the transport industry
it could travel a thousand miles without
stopping and only took 15 minutes of
downtime to refill and do another
thousand miles
the global trucking market is worth over
one trillion dollars so a disruptive
technology like this could be a game
changer if someone could make it work
that is
in a bizarre twist allegedly nicola
bought the design from a man in croatia
for a few thousand dollars but this
didn't stop the company from suing tesla
for 2 billion claiming that tesla had
stolen their design
unaware of milton's past the world was
abuzz with the news of the revolutionary
truck so how were they going to do this
exactly
well with the same technology that had
been a complete failure in the dehybrid
companies of course compressed natural
gas technology the truck was to be
revealed in a live event in december of
2016 a very tight deadline
could nicola pull it off they must have
thought that because they began to take
pre-orders they stated that the nikola
one was engineered developed and is
finalizing assembly
but what did they actually have
by august of 2016 the nikola one was
just a frame on wheels the body hadn't
even arrived yet there were no
production facilities either and
according to a source familiar with the
project the workers were scrambling to
the hardware store to pick up basic
parts
meanwhile the nikola motor company
twitter account was hyping up the event
they stressed that the truck would be
fully functioning
i missed all of this at the beginning of
august while the truck was still a frame
the company abruptly announced that it
had pivoted from compressed natural gas
to hydrogen fuel cell technology
the hydrogen fuel cell announcement was
even a shock to those within the company
in mid-november as the show was drawing
closer the team was hard at work
slapping the truck together there were
no electric motor cores or gears only
axles in an empty shell
the body finally did arrive in late
november roughly a week before the show
h2 the chemical formula for hydrogen was
decald proudly on the side of the truck
even though there was no such technology
inside
so i can understand that building a
prototype can be less than elegant but
to call this fully functioning was at
the very least a bit misleading a fact
that would later come back to haunt
nicola but more on this later in the
episode
[Music]
when the big day came trevor seemingly
couldn't hold back his emotion when
talking perhaps it was an appeal to
one's emotional side to shut down
rational thinking and skepticism
bloomberg would later state that the
statements made by trevor had alarm some
people familiar with the truck's
capability
they told bloomberg that the truck was
inoperable and had missing key
components to power itself
the whole truck was powered by a mains
power cord that was connected under the
stage
trevor would put an emphasis on the
touchscreens within the cabin seemingly
the only part of the truck that actually
functioned the whole thing was
essentially a big shiny decoration
so how long have you been working on
this because this is this is a fully
functioning truck right here that we're
sitting in so how long have you guys
been working on this uh
years in secrecy it's been very hard um
some of the some of the people have
found out about us over the last four or
five months as we announced some of the
the lead up to this big event but it
took years and years to get here um this
isn't just a pusher like a lot of
vehicles that they unveil or just
vehicles that don't actually function
there's a fully functioning uh
you know vehicle which is really
incredible you can go through you can
you know
functional or not trevor had smoothly
talked his way to entrepreneurial fame
the internet was ablaze with buzz and
from there they were off to the races
following the event in january of 2017
the company raised capital as part of
its series a round
nikola also signed with bosch as well as
fuel cell and hydrogen partners the plan
may have been to leverage existing
suppliers to deliver on their promises
but as time passed and the hype from the
december 2016 show faded people that
were following closely began talking
about the company stating that nikola
needed to show some updates on their
truck the nikola one
so
in early 2018 a video of the nikola one
was produced to dispel the rumors that
it wasn't a functioning truck the video
was called nikola one in motion
and the video seemingly worked even
arizona governor doug ducey was
impressed
he agreed to host the nikola
manufacturing headquarters in his state
and even played a video during his
announcement
and once again there was now a
tremendous amount of buzz and excitement
a lot of people were looking forward to
the pre-production units to be released
the following year but this was never to
be
it seems that trevor was up to his old
tricks again
he never really had any plans to finish
developing the nikola one truck he was
only interested in one thing
raising more money
after the 2016 announcement to the shock
of all of those involved in the nikola
one project the truck's development was
abandoned but nobody outside the company
knew this
the promotional nikola one video proved
to be a sham itself
according to a former employee he spoke
with the nikola chief engineer kevin
link the video was simply the result of
nicola towing the truck to the top of
the hill and letting it roll back down
unsurprisingly those who worked on the
video had to sign ndas
by september of 2019 trevor milton owned
40 of the company and by age 37 he was
now a billionaire
[Music]
so the company was going to use
compressed natural gas technology and
then pivoted towards hydrogen technology
they were going to use hydrogen as a
kind of fuel to power an electric motor
and why the difference well hydrogen
goes further than a battery electric
truck does and it's a lot lighter to
operate so ultimately it's just a lot of
like juggling these different things but
we're we're pretty close we just ordered
the largest order ever of electrolyzers
that i know of it was a an order
yesterday it was over 30 million dollars
for to produce over 40 000 kilograms of
hydrogen we just made that order
yesterday from nail out of norway so
we're already prepping our first five
stations to be up and running we're
breaking ground we should be breaking
down this year on these stations
okay
as good as this sounds hydrogen is
expensive and requires a lot of
engineering to store and transport
safely
the plan for nikola motors was to have
700 hydrogen stations around north
america and 70 in europe within the next
decade
nikola planned to make its own hydrogen
by using energy from solar and renewable
sources this all sounds amazing but when
you look into the details of who was
spearheading a lot of the key technology
aspects things get a little suspect
nicholas director of hydrogen production
is none other than trevor milton's
brother
previously to joining nicola his work
consisted of pouring concrete and
building a barn as a subcontractor
not exactly the experience needed
according to those familiar with the
matter travis really didn't do much of
the company he was kept around to do a
few odd jobs hold a rope here fetch
those tools and that kind of thing
trevor had given travis along with other
family members nikola motorstock worth
over 110 million dollars
[Music]
nicholas head of infrastructure
development in charge of building out
those 700 plus hydrogen station networks
was previously a general manager of a
golf club in idaho again not exactly the
experience one would expect for the job
as pointed out by kathy wood ceo of arc
invest hydrogen on average cost three
times as much as electric
trevor needed a way to fix this
in an interview trevor claimed that
nicola produces hydrogen for under three
dollars a kilogram 81 percent cheaper
than the rest of the world representing
a major breakthrough
in the hi we're really a hydro an energy
technology company we sell the energy to
consumers you know we're not consumers
but i'm sorry businesses that are buying
the trucks
that's where the money is um obviously
we want to reduce the cost of our truck
but we're now cheaper to drive than a
diesel is per mile and we make five
times the revenue of our competitors so
it's awesome i mean that's why niko's
really cracked the chicken in the egg
the generation that's investing now they
care more about the the environmental
impact of what you're doing
than they do like oh you're six months
or eight months from revenue they don't
care they're like you know what you're
changing the world you're gonna reduce
emissions more than anyone else we're
invested into you
when pressed trevor later acknowledged
that nicola produces no hydrogen at all
but this didn't stop bp later pledging
to join nikola to build out their
hydrogen fuel network
it really is amazing when you think
about it
trevor had perfected a devious game he
would act as a spokesperson for nicola
and make up lofty claims to gain
partners
essentially trevor would use these
claims to get investors and more
partners and then use the brand
recognition of those partners to get
even more investors
ultimately all of this didn't matter
though because the next piece of
technology that trevor was going to
announce was going to change the world
in late october 2019 trevor began
teasing on twitter that nicola was going
to change the world with an upcoming
announcement that was bigger than
anything that he had announced in the
past
[Music]
while he was tweeting up a storm in
november of 2019 milton cashed out 70
million dollars and bought the most
expensive house in utah a 33 million
mansion on a 2 600 acre ranch
he told the wall street journal that
this place was quote a sanctuary for my
family friends and others to enjoy
on november 18 2019 nicola began
negotiations to go public
the very next day the company announced
that it had solved one of the greatest
challenges facing sustainable energy a
high density battery
this new prototype battery would provide
four times the energy density of lithium
ion and could power a tesla model s for
over 600 miles
on twitter trevor claimed that he had
seen this technology perform with his
own eyes and promised a major
demonstration
riding high off the announcement nikola
motors began to receive serious
attention
and husa bush was first to jump on board
placing a pre-order for 800 trucks
trevor estimated that the value of this
new technology was to be worth hundreds
of billions the thing was nicola had no
patent engineers chemists or research
papers published
the truth was nicola had acquired the
battery maker zap go for 56 million
dollars
as it turned out zapgo's technology was
vaporware it was a scam it didn't exist
and so there it was
nicola who had misled so many had been
misled themselves
interestingly zap go was headed by
charles resnick a shady character who
had just scammed nasa a few months
before the nicola deal charles used the
money from nasa to hire numerous adult
workers certainly not a business expense
charles would plead guilty in january of
2020 but once again all of this didn't
matter to trevor
he was still on twitter touting the
non-existent battery technology
with nothing more than the promise of a
revolutionary truck that rolled down a
hill and a game-changing battery
technology that was purchased from a
company that was a scam nicola went
public on june 4th 2020. they did so
through a technique called a reverse
merger the thing is with reverse mergers
you don't have to disclose all the
intricate details of your company
something that a regular ipo would
require
this should have raised some red flags
for investors if they knew more about
the history of nikola but alas investors
were euphoric and nicolas shares spiked
within one week of going public the
market value of nicola surged past that
of ford over 30 billion dollars
to put things into perspective ford sold
5.5 million vehicles in 2019 with a
revenue of 155 billion and had a market
cap of around 28 billion
nicola on the other hand sold nothing
and was valued at 30 billion making it
the world's biggest truck maker without
selling a single truck
and with that overnight trevor became a
multi-billionaire it was settled the
markets had spoken he was the next elon
musk
things would soon change for trevor
though
but not before one last cash grab
on september 8th 2020 nikola motors
announced a 2 billion partnership with
general motors
gm was going to take an 11 stake in the
company and manufacture their electric
pickup truck the nikola badger
so questions have to be asked did
general motors do no research or was
something else at play here
despite the chaos nicola was again
accepting pre-orders for their badger
truck to date no one has ever seen a
nicola badger they only exist as a
rendering as far as the public is
concerned
finally after lying for years and roping
in some of the biggest companies two
days after the gm deal on september 10th
the short-selling investment firm
hindenburg research released a scathing
report calling nikola motors an
intricate fraud
the firm said it had gathered extensive
evidence including recorded phone calls
text messages private emails and behind
the scenes photographs detailing dozens
of false statements by milton
they accused him of lying about nicholas
technology
this was a bombshell report and soon the
gates were blown wide open we believe
this is only the beginning of nicholas
unraveling nico's almost no intellectual
property products or revenue to fall
back on we think the company's key asset
was its founders ability to raise money
through hype and then the hindenburg are
saying outright trevor milton knew that
this was the end and he publicly
promised a full rebuttal to all the
damaging claims but instead he deleted
his social media accounts and
disappeared
trevor milton the founder of electric
truck company nikola is voluntarily
stepping down as executive chairman and
giving up his board seat this move comes
after short seller hindenburg research
accused milton of making false
statements about nikola's technology in
order to try and grow and secure
partnerships with automakers both the
justice department and the sec are
investigating allegations made by
hindenburg
on the 21st of september trevor steps
down from the chairman position and
former vice chairman of gm stefan gursky
takes over nicholas stock plunged by 40
and negotiations between nicola and
other partners stalled and finally a
sexual assault allegation by trevor's
own cousin just added to the horrible
mess many banks liquidated their
nicholas stock seemingly in disgust
the company received a myriad of
subpoenas and investigations by the
department of justice and the securities
and exchange commission commenced his
company marketed as a game changer we've
built something that no one else thought
was possible cleaner vehicles powered by
hydrogen and electricity for every
doubter out there that said that there's
no way this is true
abs how can that be possible we've done
it but now the billionaire founder of
nikola motor company trevor milton is
being charged with securities fraud do
you have anything to say
we have a statement check it out milton
seen leaving a manhattan courthouse
thursday charged by federal prosecutors
who say he lied about every aspect of
his truck of the future milton claimed
that the nikola one could be driven when
in fact the closest it ever came to
driving was when a group of nikola
engineers took it to the top of the hill
and rolled it down so it could be filmed
for a commercial prosecutors claiming
the truck's door even had to be taped up
for the video so it wouldn't fall off
at the end of july 2021 a federal grand
jury charged trevor milton with three
counts of criminal fraud the u.s
attorney's office in manhattan accused
the 39 year old billionaire of lying to
investors making false statements about
the company and wire fraud
the sec also filed civil securities
fraud charges against him requiring the
court to permanently buy him from acting
as an officer and ordered him to pay
fines as well as give back any revenue
gained by his deceit
trevor milton of course denies all
wrongdoing and has pleaded not guilty to
the charges but this will be a matter
for the course to decide
since the charges nicholas stock has
been steadily falling
following the indictment the company
stated quote we remain committed to our
previously announced milestones and
timelines and are focused on delivering
nikola tray battery trucks later this
year from the company's manufacturing
facilities
nikola continues to move forward under
new management but it has to be said
correcting the course of a company built
on fraudulent claims by a compulsive
liar is not going to be easy
the gm deal lies in limbo and the stock
price is at an all-time low and faith in
the company dwindles every day
bosch general motors and a slew of
investors are left holding the bag
on a wider point it's becoming clear
that investors have collectively lost
their minds it seems as if they're only
driven by lofty promises without doing a
shred of research
everyone was just so excited that they
didn't want to look deeper and herein
lies the problem
think of yourself as an inexperienced
investor you heard about this new
company and it just showed off a
revolutionary truck it was powered by
new hydrogen technology and also had
amazing new battery technology they'd
partnered with major companies like
bosch and bp and this company has raised
a lot of money
you'd think you've hit a gold mine you'd
also think that you've gotten in on the
next tesla this whole train wreck really
is the old adage fake it until you make
it but what happens if the things that
you promise turn out to be much harder
than anticipated when do you pass the
point of no return and just keep lying
until you get caught for milton he just
kept lying until the very end
in a way the story of trevor milton and
nicola motors would almost be impressive
if it wasn't so morally bankrupt
maybe he did this all to provide for his
family that had suffered so much during
those early years
but it could have just as easily been
pure greed i guess we may never know
and with that that is the wild and
twisting story of nikola motors so let
me know what you think in the comment
section below so thanks for watching my
name is tagogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and i'll catch you again
soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you